Trying to film paragliding is kind of like trying to herd
pigeons, you know, like no one's ever able to stay properly
still. And the real challenge in
filming is that you still need to then like go in topland on
some snowy peak before your friends quickly jump out of the
harness, get into the back, grab out the drone, put it up in the
air and then film them. The birds are getting like
pushed out of the sky, plastic bags getting blown everywhere.
If you were under a paraglider in those moments, it's it's
really serious. And there was a real genuine
nervousness for him amongst us. And you start worrying about,
like, how are we going to launch any kind of practical rescue
mission with the weather coming in?
I somehow feel that sharing reality is more important than
sharing just the good side. If everything goes perfectly,
often it actually doesn't make for a very interesting story,
so. This is interesting.
There's no intro or anything so we just decided to press
recording and start this episode.
But I let me just welcome you for the sake of it, man.
Welcome to the show. Thanks dude.
Yeah, we're here. It's rolling.
It is finally after a long time trying, but your background
looks freaking amazing Jake. So where are you joining us from
with the Air Design Hoodie and the Monstera which we share in
the background? Well, yeah, I'm just in my
living room actually, so thanks for saying it looks nice, but
it's yeah, kind of bit of climate going on back there
probably. But yeah, just at home.
It's a a slightly cloudy day out in in the Chamonix Valley, but
it's actually turning into some nice light this evening.
So yeah. Chamonix is like, I think, one
of those words that every time an adventurer hears, there's
like, you know it, that there's so many reasons to have fun in
Chamonix. So how is life like in that
French stammer? Yeah, you're right.
I think there is so many, I don't know.
There's so many good vibes that you get about that word of
definitely. And yeah, I'm fortunate enough
to live here. I didn't live in Chamonix
itself. Actually, I live in a small
village just down the road. It's like a 12 minute drive down
the road in a little village called Servos.
And I guess I've been here on and off for the last decade now.
Just first started coming out here for the winters and then
kind of after a few years realized the summers were just
as good. And then never, never really
cooled anywhere else home since then.
And as you say, there's something for everyone here,
whether you're someone who just likes to be in a town looking up
at the mountains or going for sort of easy walks right through
to, you know, highly technical albinism or very steep skiing
and everything between that. And then of course, incredible
paragliding. We're really lucky here for
flying, actually. We get a lot of flyable days,
probably more than people would expect.
I'd actually say the winter is also good for flying, not
necessarily so good for thermal flying, but you know, as long as
it's not too windy then we've got really good lifts.
I mean, with the parakites and everything coming, I think like
the options are just expanding, you know?
Yeah, that's, I mean, that's really true.
And I think more and more you're starting to see them popping up
in in the valley. And so do you have a couple of
good soaring spots as well? Not all the time, but they're
quite nice when they come in. And and then how many film
makers live in Chamonix? Let me ask you that question.
There's there's actually quite a few get yeah, really talented
film makers that live in Chamonix.
Yeah, I'd say out of the films that you see popping up each
year, quite a few either live in Chamonix or like, you know,
frequent visitors of the place, let's say.
Is it like a place where you might bump across a big name,
you know, every now and then or you see like athlete who is, I
mean the big names is like nothing compared to the Olympic
status in conventional sports. But in our sport like, you know,
they have been legendary status and they have been doing it for
a lifetime and achieved a lot. So did you see a lot of those
people in in in Germany? Yeah, I think so.
You definitely do. You know, you can be walking
down the High Street and you'll see another famous skier like
Glenpake, or you'll see Leo, or it's just like many of the
really great alpinists and skiers and legendary people
either living in the town or visiting here.
Sounds like a cool place. Yeah, it's, it's frequent that
you see these people and kind of lucky enough to have a few of
them as my friends, which is always nice to say.
Yeah, it's it's a great place and it's a good vibe.
Dude, I was like, we came across to have this episode on the
topic of filmmaking and parametric, but I think Shamani
itself can pick up a lot of, you know, the portion of the show
because. Yeah, we should.
We should. We should move on from Shamani,
OK. You know, I'll tell you why this
thing came to my mind because I was looking at your YouTube
channel before, but you know, just when I was trying to think,
OK, how will we draft this show? And then I saw Magic of Freedom
shot in Karakoram having the most amount of views than any
other visuals which have been shot in in European geographical
location or any other place. So I'm like something in Jake
prompted him to put in or invest resources in a place which was
further out from his home, you know, So he decided to pack his
bags and put in the effort there and then.
That is his best way. His creativity has come out to
his audiences so far. But if you look at back home
itself, Shamani is, as you said, like you know, it's insanely
beautiful. There are endless opportunities
and the tribe and everything. So I'm like, we always tend to
explore because I, I come from India and I have learnt in, in
the Himalayas and I have, you know, flown in some of the most
majestic mountain ranges known to the mankind.
But then back in my head when I was starting out, I was like,
man, Europe is the place to be because over there skies look
different, the features look different, you know, so somehow
like we always find grass greener on the other end.
And in creativity, it just comes out in in very beautiful forms,
like it did in your case. Yeah, I mean, I guess
objectively I, I mean, firstly, I I don't have a very big
YouTube channel and I've it's not something that I've put any
real big investment into probably beyond this film that
you just talked about the magic freedom and.
That's a humble rag people. Jake.
Jake. No, honestly, if you don't agree
with me then then let us know in the comments below.
If that's not a hunger humble rag, you know dude, you're
closing in on 200,000 views on that video and we're talking
about the sport of parallel and an average crossing 5000 is
considered pretty good so. Yeah, not to say that that video
hasn't done, you know, way better than I thought.
And it's super fun to have read through the comments and see how
much people have enjoyed that film.
And I guess if, if people haven't seen that film, just so
you know what we're talking about, this is a film that we
made in 2023 with, with some friends in, in Pakistan out of a
town called Krimabad. And it mainly focuses in on
paragliding or using paragliders to access mountains for skiing
and climbing and alchemism. But just to quickly get back to
your thing, I guess as my profession, I'm lucky enough to
be a filmmaker. That's what I do for, for my
sort of livelihood, which is a huge privilege.
So the vast majority of actually anything that I would kind of
consider my more professional end is never going on my own
YouTube channel. You know, it's always for
clients. So that's kind of why I was
saying I haven't really put a huge amount of time and effort
into the the YouTube channel. There's definitely stuff on
there. There's some little tutorials
I've kind of done of flying and skiing and bits and pieces, but
other than the magic of freedom, I wouldn't say there's anything
in there that's sort of more of my professional scope.
And it just so happened with that film, you know, it wasn't
sponsored or anything like that, but it was very kindly helped
with a grant from Kendall Mountain Film Festival, which
was helped with a brand called Kailas.
But there wasn't sort of like a final outlet for that in a sort
of professional sense. So it just ended up going on the
YouTube channel there. And that's kind of how that
ended up being there. And also maybe why it's done
kind of considering better than anything else I've ever put on
on YouTube. OK.
So just quickly the grant plus whatever the revenue it has
generated online, has it made the effort worth it?
I think regardless of that Grant and what it made from revenue
online by the way like that's not a lot of.
Money. I didn't want to sound cheesy
man, I know the meaning behind it is much more like deep and
stuff but. I mean.
Like just on the material is. Probably like 300, but I don't
think that was ever the point of that film.
The point of that film was an expression of what the title is,
the magic of freedom. And I do just feel that
paragliding as a sport is incredibly magical and gives us
like so much freedom, especially there in these huge mountains
with paragliders. We've really been lucky enough
to explore in quite extraordinary ways just with the
power of the sky and get to places super fast where they
would, you know, potentially take kind of a classical month
long expedition and suddenly you just arrive there.
And so regardless of not of any kind of monetary income or
whatever, making that film is just a real passion project and
something that's really close to my heart.
I think the the phrase that you said, the magic of just arriving
there, man, I think that is beyond words.
Captivating because moving through like Earth like we are
designed to walk and OK we see wheels in our life pretty early
on. We have bicycles so we are only
used to moving in in a certain dimension and commercial flying.
Of course you know OK as as kids you get exposed to that point of
view as well. But para lighting is a whole
different way of immersion man. And I think this is a question I
asked you last time as well because just for the viewers to
let them know we are re recording this because last time
we had way too much fun and it was way too good to go on public
portals. But maybe my Patreon, maybe we
can do a Patreon release on that one.
So feel free to go join our Patreon channel if you want to
see what goes on behind the scene and is too censored to
make the real deal. So if the budgeting is kind of
given complete freedom, you know, you bring in the Imax's,
bring in all kinds of workforce that you need.
And if you have the budget of a feature film, then how would the
experience of flying be shown to the viewers so that they can
feel it in the most immersive manner?
Yeah. I mean, that's an interesting
question because paragliding in the grand scheme of compared to
other sports, it's received quite a, you know, a very small
amount of investment into filming.
And that's not to say that there haven't been some larger, you
know, productions because they have, you know, with like Will
GAT and Gavin and these guys, they made some really amazing
films over in in Canada and Alaska and stuff like that,
where I feel like they did have bigger budgets to make images
and stuff like that. But anyone who's a paraguiding
pilot, you know, can make really beautiful visuals with the
equipment that we have now, sort of these go pros or 360 cameras
especially. And I think you can already
transport people to some really special places with that.
I mean, to answer your question on what could be bigger, I think
this production is that John Griffiths has done recently.
I think it's called Into the Sky.
I might have got that title wrong.
I'm sorry if I have, John. That production was really
interesting and fascinating, specifically on the topic that
you're saying about bringing people into paragliding and see
what it looks like. Because they made this full
VR360 immersion video, which came out earlier this year.
And the thought and the depth that team went into, to taking a
viewer into really what paragliding is like and taking
them to some really amazing places, whether that being
Chamonix Mont Blanc or over in, in Pakistan in the Karakoram
and, and deep into the Baal Toro.
And also for wing shooting. And that film's output is
actually with a headset. And I've not actually seen the
finished products yet for a headset, but I was involved in
filming some of the behind the scenes stuff.
And I think that was a really impressive effort, far beyond
what anyone's done before for giving people a true sense of
what paragliding might be, you know, or is like.
And I'm pretty excited to put that headset on and see see
where that's going. But in terms of more, I don't
know, I guess traditional sort of films that you would see on a
on a screen, which are maybe a bit more accessible because not
everyone has these goggles, having a bigger production to
film a paragliding expedition. I mean, of course, if you were
to scale up budgets a big way and you can have helicopters.
Or drones. Or.
Yeah, or big drains or whatever. Then you could create more
impressive sort of imagery and and following them.
Of OK, OK, let me simplify it. I was like Red Bull has been
having pretty flexible budgets. You know, their media house is
having millions of dollars worth to go on with and their ex Alps
coverage has been one of the best that the sport has ever
seen. But when it comes to POV point
of view immersions in that sense, somehow we are you know,
regardless of the 4G5G networks being flown around across the
terrain and like you know, drones being used even in
agriculture and warfare and everything.
But when it comes to parallel lighting coverage, somehow we
are lacking unless you're saying this multi like I don't know,
multi million or thousand or whatever is the budget of the
production that you are talking about in VR.
So when it comes to regular productions, regular productions
are lacking somewhere. So is it just that because the
sport is being carried out in such a medium and logistically
it is insanely difficult to do things in the air, or is it like
something else which is holding the creatives back?
Are you talking about more sort of like I guess not super high
end productions, but sort of in the like what would you kind of
compare it to that you're you're trying to?
I mean, so, so let's say there is individual level productions
where for example, where a person decides to put out a
story and then you have like small brand aided productions,
which Tom Didolo and Horatio have been kind of doing for a
while. And then you have something more
organised which Red Bull exalts us.
So none of these are kind of, you know, getting close to the
point of where it is possible to stream the sport to an audience
or bring it out in a way where something live can be narrated
with live commentary or something.
That's what I'm saying. I mean, of course, documentary
style is, is, you know, completely different genre
altogether. But otherwise, when it comes to
storytelling in an immersive way, what's holding us back?
Yeah. So I mean, ultimately if you
compare maybe other events, which I think is what you may be
getting at with these kind of live broadcast things.
So I don't know Red Pool Rampage, which is a famous
mountain biking event and that's all sort of live streamed or the
free ride world tour of skiing, for example.
You know, it's relatively easy in comparison to just to film
the side of a of a mountain and have all the technology in that
one place. But the problem with paragliding
and filming it is it's a highly dynamic sport where you're
covering distance and as you've already said, you know, 3
dimensional ways. So I think for making live
events, if you're talking about like wanting to film World Cup
or something like that, yeah, it gets really difficult because
either you need other motorized aircraft like helicopters which
are incredibly expensive, or you need people who are also flying
on paragliders. And as we know, the trouble with
flying paragliders is it's it's quite an involved sport.
So trying to then film from there and follow the athletes
whilst you're also thermaling and stuff.
Of course it's possible and but to put that out in any kind of
like very high quality capacity, I think it's a challenge just
because of those dynamics involved.
I'll tell you why I had that thought process, because the the
VR film that you're talking about with Meta was more or less
filled on a tandem rig, right? You you guys had a professional
guy piloting and then another professional holding the camera
gear further below, which was fairly heavy.
So I was just thinking that drive to survive series by
Netflix is basically showing internal like, you know, solo
battles or how the team dynamics work.
And that's why it's like very captivating way to grab users
attentions or viewers attentions.
And if you look at any paragliding race, it is insanely
full of high adrenaline and everything, you know,
considering what really a pilot feels who's running for the the
top spot or, or, you know, at any point in the gaggle, it's
it's quite an exciting place to be as a human.
But is that like the closest we can come?
You know, maybe putting on a tandem and having a professional
controlling a camera and a professional controlling the
wing and maybe, of course, having tandems match triple C's
is going to be hard. But then, you know, having
multiple set ups in multiple places, for example, let's say
Crocevo, it has a very defined racing circuit.
It has a very, you know, selected boundaries.
And of course, you can't keep up with the triple C's all across
the circuit, but you can place your cameraman in the air
strategically. And then if some sort of this
setup becomes more popular and revenue streams start opening
up, then maybe the World Cups or like the sport can evolve
according to the telecast. Because telecast or the viewers
will like, you know, decide the growth trajectory of how the
races are held or how the tracks are held or so that is the only
way to kind of try and fuse these two ways to make it more
successful, I think. Yeah, I mean, first of all, like
I just want to say I really don't know much about cross
country racing. Like it's not something I've
really ever done. It's not something I like
particularly follow. So I'm probably not the best
person to be having the conversation with AAI guess.
I mean, I think my filmmaking is much more from a documentary
style of you and following like adventures and stuff.
And that's that's kind of what gets me excited.
I think if you wanted to make some kind of drive to survive
esque style of paragliding, then of course you could.
You could do that and there'll be various ways of, of, of doing
it, I imagine. And like anything, it just comes
down to good storytelling and, and stuff.
And obviously the drive to survive, for example, that's not
a live broadcast thing. That's that's made with a lot of
really interesting interviews. And as you, as you said, what
makes that fascinating is much more the human element of that
and seeing what goes on sort of behind the races and after the
races. And I'm, I'm sure someone with
the, the right passion could, could do that within paragliding
racing. I think maybe the the, it's that
chicken and egg situation. What came first, you know, like
crowd support of motor racing versus, you know, them more
people wanting to see it. And I feel like with paragliding
at the moment, even if you were to make quite a high end
production, is there the audience there to watch it?
I don't know, maybe. I'm sure if it was done in a big
enough compelling way. But ultimately the sport of
paragliding is, you know, a pretty small and and niche sport
when we compare it to to the other sports that are out there.
I think deep down, Jake, that is because the ones who practice it
are simply too spellbound by its beauty that they just don't put
in the effort of telling or like haven't found the right way to
tell how beautiful it is. And the day that happens where
you're really able to tell people who have not seen that
way of life. I think it is it is just a
market waiting. Do we have because it's a birth
time wish. Every human wishes to fly.
It is something resembling with freedom, as your title suggests.
And I think it's only a matter of time until somebody finds the
right way to tell that story. But coming to storytelling, you
know, let's let's talk about that one because the Magic of
Freedom is a very self-explanatory title.
I would say makes you think it makes you kind of, yeah.
Visualize. So what's the, what's the back
story of Magic of Freedom? I'm really keen to ask you about
the logistics and how you took the shots deep down in the
mountains when you were flying, like, you know, at a place where
batteries freeze pretty quickly. But from title to the red
carpet, let me just put it back. How was the journey in Magic of
Freedom in cargo rooms? I mean, as you say, the title is
quite like self-explanatory, I guess.
And it hopefully does evoke sort of some kind of emotion in
people when they they read those words and maybe they want to
sort of watch the film to find out what that is.
But the the passion for it, I think it just came, you know,
from doing these things and then wanting to to share that with
people because it does feel really special.
You know, I think flying in the caricorum, I think paragliding,
regardless of where you do it more or less feels really
special as humans moving through that 3D space and that old
age-old kind of wish of wanting to fly.
You know, paragliding is without doubt a special sport.
But then when you combine in sort of the majesty of huge
Himalayan mountains around you, which you just incredibly
sculpted and beautiful, and that opens up a whole another can of
worms and it just makes for unbelievable photos and video.
I think so, yeah. I just guess it came from a wish
to wanting to share that with people.
I think everybody, anybody who flies is very excited to tell it
to their at least close family and friends.
So we all try to, you know, have our own Gopros and everybody's
excited to show their closest people that, hey, look, I did
this and it's so cool. But very few of us actually
managed to put in the effort that goes behind doing it.
So how did the post production life look for you?
What was that all about? Did you outsource it?
Are you doing it yourself or what was that about?
I feel like anytime you go on a trip like that, you can have
goals and objectives, but you don't really know what you're
going to achieve. And I mean, that film came off
the back of the first film I did in Pakistan called The New Way
Up, which was with Will Simmons and Fabi Bull when they made the
first ascent of Gommet Tower. And again, on that trip, you
know, we went to Pakistan, we brought climbing stuff, we
bought skiing stuff, and we set out to see what we'd end up
doing. And actually for a lot of that
first trip, we didn't have particularly great weather and
it looked like we probably wouldn't get anything
particularly of note done. But just at the end, the boys
pulled out this, you know, really amazing expedition, I
guess, of climb on the Gomit Tower.
And I was lucky enough to sort of go along with them and film
it and kind of thought about before we went in and after to
get all the content that we needed.
And we made that. And the magic of freedom was
very similar. We went back to Pakistan for six
weeks or something like that, maybe a little bit longer.
And I just started filming stuff along and you kind of hear what
people might want to do and start shooting little interviews
here and there and thinking about the scenes that you want
to capture. But I wouldn't say there was a
huge plan. So post production at the end of
it, you know, like I think is a filmmaker, you need to be
thinking a bit ahead and you need to think about the contents
that you need. You need to think about where
you're going to get the interviews.
You need to think about what kind of shots you're going to
have. But the actual story, I mean,
that just unfolded entirely naturally and that was capturing
it. And then at home you kind of
have all this stuff and then you got to think about the best way
to put that together in a logical way.
And I think in this case in a, you know, in kind of quite a
nice way. We had actually way too much
content because we had so many fun adventures whilst we were
there. The stuff you see in that film,
of course, they're all like amazing things, but for every
one of those stories, there's several others and several other
good flights. So in a kind of sad way, you
actually have to end up chopping out a lot of stuff because you
need to make something that's has kind of a thread throughout
it. And and throughout that was
using paragliders to access these Himalayan peaks, whether
it be for climbing or whether it be for skiing.
And that's kind of the main theme, I guess throughout the
throughout the film. So, yeah, I mean, budget wasn't
big for that film. As I said before, I had a, a
grant from Kendall Mountain Film Festival, which was funded by
Kailas, but it wasn't, you know, it wasn't a lot of money.
It wasn't enough money to pay for like the trip and all the
time and all the editing. So it was sort of a project of,
of passion really. But the post production I got
some help with some graphics because I'm not particularly
good with, with that. And I got a little bit of help
with some colour stuff, although in the end that wasn't maybe the
the best. But yeah, beyond that, it was
just kind of myself and the support of friends who are kind
enough to watch stuff and Give your opinion.
And, and and then you battle onwards and cut more out or add
more in and until you have something where you finally have
to stop. Normally that's because of the
like a deadline. And that was the case with it
was there was a deadline for the Kendall Mountain Film Festival.
So you can only go so far. I, I feel that while editing out
the trailers of my podcast, because sometimes, you know, the
62nd trailers are almost taking up to a whole day to edit.
You know, I'm like bringing in some transitions, some swooshes
and like sounds and overlays and you know, different effects.
And The thing is that you can never be fully satisfied that
how good this looks because every time you go look back and
you're like, oh, maybe this thing I can, I can make this
look better. All right, I can make this small
little change if it makes this difference.
And then ultimately, as you said, that having a deadline
helps where you're like, fine, you know, now I need to stop
working on this because otherwise you can always keep on
making certain improvements. But yeah, man, it's it's it's an
exciting, you know, the way you narrated, like I can find it
very easy to relate. But what did your hardware look
like? You know how many drones
batteries like because these things are expensive.
The the considerable amount of money goes into buying a high
end action Cam and God forbid if you lose 1 in any of adventures
that then you're like the motivation to invest again.
Because I have sadly lost out on an insta 360 once and and it was
like I had to buy another one instantly because it was so hard
to survive. But how did the hardware side of
things look like for you and how did you manage all of that?
Yeah, as you say this, the hardware like cameras, drones,
action cameras, these things aren't cheap per SE.
I think if you were to look at it from a film production point
of view, if you were to look at it professionally, people would
probably say is a very minimal amount of kit.
So I had with me a little Sony kind of full frame hybrid
camera. I think it was an A7C1 or an
A7C2, I can't remember which one it was.
Three €3000 maybe ish. Yeah, probably a little less
than that, I'd imagine, for the body.
But that camera, you know, it's capable of making incredible
images. And we live in a a real golden
age for filming stuff now. Yeah, what consumers can buy,
like into the 360 you could only dream of a few years back in
reality. And it's the same with that
little camera that I used. I mean, the quality of that
sensor is, if you go back not that long ago, it's just as good
as the top of the line cameras. And then, of course, lenses are
important. So I probably had like a 16 to
35 with me and then this 24 to one O 5, which is a very
versatile lens. I I will say like a lot.
I do not understand the clue, and I'm pretty sure there are a
lot of listeners who don't understand the numbers that you
just said, so if you're explicit.
I mean, those numbers, they're just they're focal lengths
numbers. So that's how zoomed in or not
zoomed in the images. So like 16 would be quite wide
and 105 would be more, more tight.
But yeah, I think having different lenses gives you
different options for creating different visuals, whether you
want to be more zoomed in on on someone and sort of like a
interview kind of portrait or having a nice wide lens to
document the the amazing mountains.
And then of course, you know, like a go pros and 360 cameras,
they've become more and more important for shoots, especially
in action shoots. You want to have a camera on
someone so the audience feels immersed in into that place.
And I think in paragliding, just because of the difficulties of
this, of filming that sport, these kind of small action
cameras are really important because you know, if you go
mountain biking or something and you want to make a mountain
biking film, you just walk around the woods and you get
your friends to come past you a bunch of times or come down this
mountain. It's logistically, it's quite
simple compared to trying to film paragliding, which is kind
of like trying to herd pigeons. You know, like no one's ever
able to stay properly still. And you know, everyone's moving,
you're moving, you need to be concentrating on that.
So I think the biggest, probably most helpful tool, at least
let's say that for making the really impressive visuals was
the use of a drone. So I think I had a Mavic 3, DJI
Mavic 3 Pro on that shoot, which, you know, it's an
incredible drone. It's not super heavy in the
grand scheme of things for climbing mountains with and
having it with you. You've got probably an extra
kilo and 1/2 or two kilos with extra batteries and stuff.
So it's trips where weight is such an important factor.
But the cool thing about that is it's much easier to chase
pigeons with than it is flying a paraglider yourself.
That's not to say that some of the images aren't, you know,
shot from the paraglider, but I I feel like a lot of the more
breathtaking images are often with the drone because you just
have that much more independent control of being able to go up
and down and round to the side of someone and you're much less
restricted because ultimately it's a a powered tool.
And but the the the problem with the drone is it's not like
simple in the sense that you can't just sit at the bottom of
the mountain and film people as they fly off up to 6 or 7000
because the drone can't go that far legally not meant to fly
that high. So the real challenge in filming
still is that you still need to paraglide.
You still need to then like go in topland on some snowy peak
before your friends quickly jump out of the harness, get into the
back, grab out the drone, put it up in the air and and then and
then film them. So it's an amazing tool for
capturing really spellbinding images, but it's not without,
you know, still the hassle and everything else.
But I do think that is probably the best way that I've been able
to get some of the really stunning images there in that
film. I think cinemat incident,
paragliding cinematography, like parallax shot, uh, I mean, you
feel free to explain what parallax means to the viewers,
but I think they are one of the most, uh, captivating ones where
you just don't want to look away and you're so glued to the
screen because of the, the scale that, you know, the way the
whole scene is unfolding in front of the audiences.
And those ones can only be taken by drones because I have tried
to film a fair bit. And I think in flight filming is
one of the most easiest ones where you just pull out your
camera, hold it in your hand, secure it with a latch like a
tie somewhere and then put it back in your harness pocket or
whatever is your storage. But then Parallax, where the
audience feel insanely immersed, is only possible withdrawn,
which has its own all new logistical.
Yeah. I mean, I'm not sure of the
actual technical definition of parallax, but I believe parallax
is where you have a camera moving around an object and the
zoom is enough that the background kind of looks like
it's almost going the other way. Yeah, yeah.
And I would almost argue that, you know, with things like a
Mavic 3 and stuff, even that's relatively hard to make because
you need a certain amount of of zoom to the images.
And like most of the really incredible parallax images that
you've probably seen in paragliding or where you have
that kind of zoomed in background feel and you see it
rushing past the screen, but the the subject is still staying
right in the middle. A lot of those images would be
shot from from helicopters with like a shot over setup, kind of
remote controlled gimbled camera off off of there.
But I mean, what's really cool is that technology and drones
and stuff, it is just getting better and better.
And certainly with like bigger drains now that you can change
the lenses on and stuff, these are capable of making
unbelievable shots. We're talking even bigger drones
and stuff, which you can definitely take up onto the
mountains if you've got the kind of passion and the will to do it
and you're willing to sacrifice all the extra effort.
But if you're also trying to achieve something like skiing
down a mountain or whatever it might be, ultimately there is
kind of a weight limit of what you can A fly with and B, then
do something with. So for me, something like the
Mavic 3 is at the top of that scale.
But I think it's really worth bringing because it's being able
to get really cool shots with it.
But as you say, the the kind of easier shots.
So maybe having a GoPro on a selfie stick and then turning
that round and filming yourself or maybe friend nearby that.
I think it's so cool how technology's evolving so fast
and for smaller productions and film makers like myself, you
know, who are trying to make stuff happen without having huge
monster budgets and helicopters and everything that goes with
that in terms of emissions and all of that kind of stuff.
We're really lucky to have the technology we have now.
And I think you can still transport viewers to a pretty
high level of sort of imagery. And then obviously what makes
any film special is beyond the imagery.
You know, it's the story that you choose to tell, it's the
characters in there, and it's how you string that all
together. And I think the reality is like
a very good filmmaker could tell an incredible story with quite
nothing special, just an iPhone or whatever we have now.
And you know, when I think back to films.
Like the Birdman of Caracara or John Sylvester and I, I don't
know what cameras exactly they had then, but I can guarantee
that they would probably would only love to have what we have
now. And you watch those films on
YouTube and I don't know when they were shot, but I guess
early 2000s. But the story that they tell is
just incredible. And that's what makes those
films so special. It doesn't actually matter about
the images that much. It's just such great
storytelling and it's so compelling to watch because you
see these people having these spellbinding adventures.
I know I you know, I've watched this movie called A Temple in
the Skies shot and beer billing, you know, by two adventurers.
I'm forgetting their names. Honestly man, that footage is
nothing compared to modern day outputs.
But I can watch that movie more, more times than I can watch my
own GoPro footage from equally stunning places, you know, But
the way they tell that story and the adventures they have and the
humor and, you know, like the connection of the community and
everything, it's like, oh, geez, the ingredients to tell the
story are super amazing in that one.
And yeah, but also Red Bull came out with the first ski descent
of Mount Everest, I think a couple of weeks ago.
You had a chance to watch that. I did actually see like I kind
of saw glimpses of that and it's just quite, I don't know if
there's different copies of that or what.
But the copy that I saw, it was just kind of like a quite a raw,
fairly uncut kind of feeling with lots of drone shots.
And, and you just witnessed this dissent over quite a long time.
Is that what you also saw? That that is the only coffee
that is out there. And that is what like, to be
honest, I got like, OK, you might be looking at it from a
very technical point of view, but I kill you.
Too, I think it's, you know, it's like, well, I think it is
very technical. I think for those images at that
altitude, there's no doubt that there's a huge amount of
technicality to that. Yeah.
I think you could describe the storytelling as, you know, it's
very linear and just very simple.
It's just the uncut copy of of him skiing down off this
mountain. Yeah.
And it's just very pure in its form.
But it's it's really cool to see, you know, something like
that and see just it unfolding as it as it goes.
Yeah. It's amazing.
That that's what I was saying. I was like, I was blown away
with the how insanely immersive it was and I could not look away
as soon as I clicked, you know, I, I ended up watching the whole
30 minutes worth of that video, which was more or less the case
with your freedom of magic of freedom as well.
But but yeah, like the way you can tell a story is so many, you
know, variations and people have been doing it successfully in,
in their own niches. Uh, like as you said, John
Sylvester or temple in disguise. They had their own way and then
this, no dialogue, just breathing and visuals, shows us
another way. Well, you know, one thing that
makes me think a lot is that I'm fascinated by Yon Baptiste.
His way of telling a story is mind blowing, man.
The creativity that he shows in his videos and the way he brings
you along to what he wants to share, especially his last one,
which was kind of emotional because it was a tribute to his
parents. But Oh my God, man, somebody,
somebody said it's AI and he clarified that it's not.
Instead, it's like 5 months of relentless frame by frame
editing. Have you had a chance to see it?
I have seen it. Yeah, it's, yeah.
It's beautiful. I mean, like all of his films,
they're, they're absolutely incredible and just so well.
And they're just ultimately they're very unique.
Can't they? You know, they've got a lot of
thought into them. They've thought heavily on the
idea behind the film before shooting yet and coming up with
all these incredible scenes. And the one you're talking about
now is this latest one where you don't see the paraglider other
than a couple of water reflections, which I think is
genius. And it's just the sky sort of
flying through the sky in a slightly funny position.
But yeah, I mean, it's absolutely incredible.
And yeah, I can't even imagine the the editing that went into
that. I'm not any great special
effects or after effects kind of person.
That's not the skill set that I have, unfortunately.
But it's the concept behind it is just so well thought through
and the execution is even more amazing.
And yeah, it's a real tearjerker at the end for the kind of the
the story then he's he's sharing.
He's a very unique storyteller. And I think that's why his
videos, you know, they transcend past the size of the audience of
paragliding and they go on to a much larger audience who might
not have even seen paragliding before.
And I think it is very special. And when when people are capable
of doing that with these short films, because ultimately
there's so much content you can watch out there on YouTube or
Instagram or wherever you get your content.
And his videos, I think they always pull people into our
sport who might not have seen it before.
I was going to say that the editing part, like when you have
to, you know, take out the risers and everything else that
he has that including the, I don't know the harness or
whatever, but is it frame by frame that every single frame
you have to go select it, remove it and then replace it.
I, you know, honestly, I don't know what the workflow was
behind that. I'm not the man to ask.
There's way more people who are tech savvy with that kind of
level of editing, but I expect it probably is frame by frame
and through it and painting stuff out.
Yeah, perhaps with AI they're able to get some help on that.
I'm not sure. But clearly they had this
concept and they must have tried it first quite a lot and
involved the right sort of film makers and editors and After
Effects people to to have made it happen.
It's a very thoughtful project and it wouldn't have just been
like all shot and then all edited.
They would have had to have trialed it first and to come up
with whatever techniques that they used to make it happen.
It's like I think what would happen if Young Baptiste plus
this new technology that you said was used in the Meta
project, you know, if the combination of both of these
come together, man, I think the result is going to be pretty
much the best thing that has happened on para lighting
content creating so far. Yeah, I mean, there's always a
different way to tell the story. And as I say, I've not I've not
seen the the VR 360, the finished film yet.
So I don't know what storytelling that they use for
them. I'm sure it's very captivating
and not just from the technology, but I'm sure it's
great also from the the storytelling as well.
But yeah, there's so many ways to tell stories and there's so
many different pieces of technology that you can evolve
into them. And it's just really, it's a
cool time to be alive and it's a cool time to be working as a
filmmaker because you get inspired by these people that do
these amazing things, you know? And tell us something about the
project. Man, this seems like a very
exotic project, something never seen before in the sport.
So yeah, what was it? Which?
The VR project. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I think that project was
just really groundbreaking in so many ways, from speaking to John
quite extensively about it at the time.
Who's John? John is the director behind it,
John Griffith. He's the guy who, you know, he,
he brought that whole production to life.
He is kind of the guy in 360 VR Adventure sports who his first
film was about going up Everest and then he did like a free solo
film with Alex Honnold really, you know, like leading this
charge in 360 virtual reality. He really, I would say there's
probably no one else really. I mean, sorry if I'm cutting
people out there, but there's, you know, there's not many
people working in that space. And I think that's for several
reasons that that project was just really groundbreaking
because before then he had only ever worked with cameras that
were held statically. So as a viewer, when you put on
the headset, you weren't moving around at all.
You know, you have basically mounted to some form of tripod
or pole or something like that. And then you were just sat there
kind of to observe on the action.
And he had said, you know, to film flying that wouldn't work
because you can't film flying statically flying.
The whole point of flying is that you're moving in this
three-dimensional. But the problem that they had
always had in this 360 VR stuff is that when you put on a
headset and you start to move, that you're actually, you know,
realize you're stationary, your body doesn't like it and it
makes you feel quite nauseous and sick.
That can be really uncomfortable sensation.
So John put in a huge amount of time and effort and investment
in technology to work out how the camera could be moving but
held very, what's the word on a gimbal or whatever.
So there's no jerks, there's no wobbles.
The horizon always stays the same and you don't suddenly
speed up or you don't suddenly slow down because I think it's
those forces of acceleration that you end up feeling sick.
But to do that, it made the project really complicated in
terms of how he needed to hold the camera when flying.
So yeah, he they had the the tandem and below the tandem
there was a gimbal which was attached to a big pole or maybe
it was a pole and then the gimbal and then the camera don't
remember exactly which way around with the technology
worked. And then various kind of like
fans and motors to hold everything so it didn't wobble.
But you know, when you're taking off from places that are already
quite an ambitious take off for a tandem once, ever taken off
from there with a tandem before and then you have this hanging
bag of stuff below you, It's pretty terrifying to watch and
potentially really expensive because you just have one small
crash with that stuff and then it breaks.
Then you know, they're all custom made stuff.
So I think the whole project was incredibly ambitious.
And then where they pushed it, you know, we went and we landed
up on sort of five and a half 1000 meters and camped there for
the night with all those things following that story.
It was just a very, very ambitious project that was
already doing things with paragliders that's, you know,
most people would regard as fairly cutting edge, and then
having big drains along with you in this rig that I just
described. So if you do have access to one
of these VR headsets, whether you own one or can go to a
library or, or whatever it is, and you get to see that film, I
think just bear in mind the sort of, yeah, the vision it took to
bring all that together. And actually there's, there is a
behind the scenes film which I was involved in in, in filming
there, which doesn't show all of the things that that we did, but
definitely shows some of them. And I think you get a an idea of
how much work that production took.
OK, the thing that makes me so curious is that operating in
these hostile environments, you know, I can label it like that
because releasing the brake handles and bringing out your
selfie stick itself is quite challenging a lot of times.
But and having this whole rig and another person and close
listening to it and another glider.
What was the biggest challenge that you guys had while on this
project? You know, because anything from
sleeping overnight and freezing temperatures to waking up with a
with a colleague with a bad mood, like, what was the time
when nerves were running high on everyone?
Yeah, I mean, maybe we can go back to the magic of freedom
film because I feel like I can talk about that bit more freely
because that was my production. So I think on any of these
projects, you're, you know, you're kind of worried about
your friends and yours safety in these in these places.
And ultimately you are just out on an adventure.
And in the Magic of Freedom, you know, Antoine Gerard, he's one
of the sort of the main protagonists of that film.
He decided he was going to try to climb this mountain called
Duran, which is a little bit over 7000 meters.
And he was going to do it by himself.
How he came to doing it by himself was I think other people
had been keen, but conditions and and sort of schedules and
stuff of that trip just ended up being that he he did go for it
by himself and it was ended up being I think a pretty harrowing
experience for Antoine in the end.
You know, he made the summit, but he was moving through
terrain. That is not the safest kind of
terrain to be moving, even as a roped party because of crevasses
and stuff like that. But at least if you are a party
of two or three people, you can be tied together.
And there is techniques for what happens if you fall in a in, in
into a crevasse because you have a rope on and the other people
can kind of act as like an anchor and then pull you out.
But because he was by himself, yeah, there was quite a real
chance that he could have fallen into a crevasse and gone a long
way into it and either died from falling because some of them
are, you know, like you're 70 meters deep or just fallen down
and not, you know, being able to get himself out because he's
fallen 10 meters. And maybe he wouldn't have been
injured, but he couldn't climb out for whatever reason.
And yeah, so that really was taking a lot of kind of risks by
doing that summit by himself. And we lost comes with Antoine.
You know, we had been in comes with him on the way up, but then
we kind of lost comes with him. And it was pretty worrying, you
know, the next morning, we still weren't able to get him.
And as you see in the film, the weather sort of starts to
change. And there was, you know, a real
genuine nervousness for him amongst us.
And you start worrying about like, well, how are we going to
launch any kind of practical rescue mission with the weather
coming in? And in the end, he was able to
take off. But I think it was kind of a
pretty close thing. And he was suffering from
altitude sickness and hadn't had any real sleep the night before
and stuff. And he got down just in time,
which, you know, was amazing. And you know, he did manage to
get himself off and he did manage with with the skill and
stuff that he had said to pull it all off.
But it was a close run thing because you get these huge cloud
bursts come through with like large amounts of wind and stuff.
And that that did come in, you know, in the film, you see it
happen, feels like it happens pretty quick.
And that was the reality. You know, we were then kind of
like an hour of him landing. We had this huge weather storm
come in. And we're talking gusts of wind
when they happen in in in that place of Koruna bad.
I I wouldn't be able to give you an actual gauge.
Aaron, what they are. Aaron described that even the
stones on the road were rolling. It was.
Yeah, exactly. I mean, that is what happens and
you see it several times in a season.
And when it happens, you you could look at the sky.
If you arrived at the place you'd be like, oh, we could do
fly now. It just looks a bit overcast,
but it's actually a, you know, one or two, several big storm
cells above you. And yeah, like, there's dust
blowing everywhere. Birds are getting like, pushed
out of the sky, plastic bags getting blown everywhere.
It's if you are under a paraglider in those moments,
it's it's really serious. So yeah, I guess what I'm trying
to say is that when we are in these places that the adventure
kind of comes first and the filming second because it's it's
a proper adventure. And you know you're doing your
best to capture what you can, but you also have to look after
yourself and look after your friends.
I I've seen that and I I can completely understand what you
mean because I think Antoine did not even speak much when he
landed to capture his expressions or emotions because
he was just like, yeah, you know, wanted to finish it.
And you could feel the distress in her in his voice when he was
recording that difficult night on the round.
And I don't think he recorded the take off.
He just recorded mid flight for the sake of it.
But you know, the question that I want to ask you is, and this
can probably be a message to the viewers as well.
A lot of times whenever we want to portray something that we do,
we hide our deepest vulnerabilities.
It's, it's not comfortable bringing out our things that
scare us, especially in this context when things can go
haywire pretty quickly and, and emotions can go on a sinusoidal,
you know, like one time you're super high, one time you're
super low. We only tend to share one side
of the emotion. I somehow feel that sharing
reality is more important than sharing just the good side.
Don't want to put you in a spot by any means but Red Bull X Alps
constantly censors their output that has been given to their
audiences. Umm don't.
What's your thought on this man? Like we as pilots should be
sharing the reality right? Like, OK, you get to fly over
the clouds, but hey, this is the price that might come with it,
so be aware. Yeah, I mean, I can't speak for
Red Bull X Alps, and I have no idea what they censor or don't
censor, so I can't really comment on that.
I think I guess it goes with human nature.
I mean, if you look at people's social media feeds or whatever,
they're often filled with highlights of life and the best
moments. But that's not to say that I
feel like actually what social media actually often does is
filters out in the middle. Because of course, when someone,
when people do hurt themselves, they often do share those
stories. OK, some people don't want to
share an accident, and I think that's totally fine.
Like it's a very personal decision as to what you want to
share. But when we scroll through a lot
of social media is often the highlights of our lives.
And I guess that's kind of natural.
But I think there's of course value in, in sharing, you know,
whatever you want to, but from a storytelling point of view.
You know, if everything goes perfectly, often it actually
doesn't make for a very interesting story from point of
view of someone who is interested in making documentary
films and stuff. You're often not looking for
perfect moments. You want to capture when things
don't maybe go as planned, because those are the
interesting parts. And I think in The Magic of
Freedom, Antoine did give a very open and honest expression of
what happened when he had just landed there.
He was quite obviously, like, hard.
And you could see the fear in him.
And it was a really raw moment. And we had been super worried
about him. And, you know, you can see how
tired he is and stuff. And yeah, I guess from a film
point of view, if we only capture the peak moments, then
there's nothing to balance that out and there's nothing to make
it show why that thing is is hard and worthy of people's
attention. I think from people wanting to
make their own content, like you said, I'm not sure if it
necessarily has to be, you know, these like low moments or middle
moments or whatever. But I think if you want to make
something that people are going to connect with, there needs to
be that human element. Yeah, it's that that human
element is what makes US feel things and want to connect with
people. And good storytelling usually
has that. Not always, but often.
And I mean, there's so many different ways.
And reflecting back on what you said with the Everest thing,
which is just raw and cut, you know, that's very powerful in
itself. But most of the time, if you
just roll with a GoPro, filming it can be really beautiful, but
you don't necessarily actually connect to that experience as
much as when someone's telling you about it or see the joy or
the the fear or whatever it might be on on their face in
those moments. That is so well said my man.
I am totally satisfied with your answer and I hope the viewers
out as well. I'm glad glad it helps.
What are what are you planning to tell us next?
Well. There's some, there's some
projects in the pipeline. I can't necessarily say what
they are right now, but there's, there's definitely things to
come. And in a in a similar vein of
what we've already been working on because I feel like
ultimately when you really get into something and you start to
love it, you invest in it and you want to do more of that.
So I think there's still adventures to be had and around
the world and more stories to be told with paragliders and
whether they'll be successful or not, who knows.
And I guess that's part of the excitement is that when you go
on these expeditions and stuff like that, yeah, you don't know.
But actually, I tell you what, there is going to be something
coming out. I don't know exactly when.
I think it's going to be soon, but it's going to be an
adventure that I was with Tom and harass you over in Tanzania.
And yeah, I think people are going to enjoy that when that
comes out. And I think it's going to be a
little bit different how it's presented.
So I can't say more than that, but yeah.
Is it, is it, Is it killing again or some other?
I'll just Yeah, yeah. You'll know when it comes.
Yeah, yeah, I think it's going to be super exciting.
But I love those point of view shots and the smoke and the the
whole topography and everything. But yeah, I can see that you
don't want to divulge any more secrets, so I won't make you do
that. But yeah, hopefully, hopefully
get lucky enough to join some more trips and, and keep, keep
getting to do these great things and, and yeah, fingers crossed
there'll be some more successful stories to to share with people.
Yeah, man, I'm keep coming back to paragliding apples.
When you have new adventures to share, you know that's the whole
point. Thank you for having me on here
to talk about them. Dude, it was so natural.
You know, usually I start pressing, preparing some sort of
a draft to press recording and then go with it or something.
But this one, I'm so glad we just spontaneously decided to
press record and then it's just, I think we went on a lot of
tangents. I don't even know which all
topics we covered I'll have to review now.
And a few things there to get through, but I think, yeah, I
mean it's in super funds, it's chat with you and that's what
these things are about. Cool man, thanks for your time
and looking forward to next outputs from you in whichever
form they come from, so good luck.
Thanks.